Bruce is there a position of privilege
though that allowed you and rob reiner
and Chad Griffin to come together to
make that happen and what are the things
that you weighed or didn't weigh that
convinced you that this was the way to
go because there was as in many other
areas different perspectives on strategy
in the civil rights movement you know
the strategy of Martin Luther King was
radically different from the strategy of
Malcolm X and different from what's Nick
was doing and in the LGBT movement there
are also different strategies and voices
why why did you choose that strategy and
what what convinced you that that was
wrecked one visibly any others that were
on the table at that time well the
veiling current strategy for LGBT people
to get our rights was the legislative
strategy which was elections and a lot
of that actually going back 20 or 30
years had was actually forced upon us
which was the the opponent's putting
pudding referendums on ballots in states
to take away or rights and they were
winning the of the all of the there's
been like over 50 initiatives on state
ballots regarding LGBT rights in the
country and we've lost all but one of
them and that brought Rob Reiner and
Chad Griffin and dustin lance black and
myself as it had brought many others in
different movements before them to
realize as I was saying before hold on
why are we waiting for we're waiting for
a majority of Americans to decide we
have rights it is not their right to
decide what is constitutional and what
isn't the Constitution exists as a
document and we are entitled to that
protection and when you're not receiving
the
tection you believe you are given in the
Constitution and the amendments had been
passed you go to the courts and ask for
those rights and that's what had
happened in brown v board of education
in loving versus Virginia in in the the
different LGBT cases that had come up
Romer V Colorado and Bowers be Hardwick
and so we got excited about following in
that tradition and the initial question
that we wanted to explore first for
ourselves is do we truly believe that
when you hear the arguments that
preventing same-sex any two people from
getting married when any other two
people can't get married is that
unconstitutional in according to the
Federal Constitution and the more that
we studied it and as we brought on Ted
Olson and David Boies who come from the
two opposite sides of the political
spectrum the more that we understood the
path passion with which they believed
that they have a winnable argument the
more the more excited we got about
becoming one of those cases I mean that
was you know the dream from the
beginning is you know and II win or lose
as painful it would as it would be to
lose you know the these seminal cases
they don't they come along they changed
the course of American history and it
was time for that case to come along on
the gay marriage issue because it's the
gay marriage issue has become the sort
of the leading edge of the LGBT civil
rights movement